okay everyone good morning this is Jack
Van Horn from the bd2k training
coordinating Center based at the
University of Southern California and
I'd like to welcome everyone to the next
in our in our series of a big data to
knowledge guide to the fundamentals of
data science today we're going to be
hearing from dr. zachary ives from the
University of Pennsylvania he's going to
be discussing data provenance challenges
benefits and research dr. Ives is a
professor of computer and information
science at the University of
Pennsylvania as well as the newly
appointed associate dean for masters and
professional programs at the University
of Penn's School of Engineering and
Applied Science he's the co-founder of
Blackfin incorporated which is a company
focused on enabling life sciences
research and discovery through data
integration and his research interests
include data integration sharing
management of big data sensor networks
data provenance and authoritative 'no
sippy ins of an NSF Career Award and an
alumnus of the DARPA computer science
study panel and information science and
technology advisory panels he's
co-authored textbooks many influential
articles and were absolutely delighted
to hear about his work on data
provenance that is the attaching of
metadata but also by whom that data
comes from under what conditions the
processing steps that were used and all
the things that we call provenance so a
zachary thank you very much for joining
us we really look forward to your
lecture great thanks very much jack and
thanks everyone for joining as Jack said
I have worked on a variety of topics
broadly related to kind of a
computational support for bringing
together data from many places and of
course once you start to integrate and
reuse data all sorts of questions arise
about where the original data came from
and how it was assembled and so on and
so you know I see Providence as a key
part not only of data science
especially of data science when you're
trying to share and reuse data so my
goal today is to try to give kind of a
high-level overview of the main
abstractions and models for how we think
about provenance some of the benefits of
provenance some of the open challenges a
little bit of a hint at where a lot of
the open problems and the active
research is in this space I should
probably note as I go into this that the
NIH bd2k program is currently funding
three different efforts in the
provenance space so there's our group at
Penn there's a group out of Case Western
and a group out of Duke and we're all
trying to kind of work together in a
coordinated fashion to make services
that might be reusable across kind of
the broader bd2k portfolio so with that
let me see if I can actually dive in a
little bit into why we actually care
about provenance as I do that I should
probably emphasize there are actually
several different terms used for roughly
the same ideas so I think the sort of
standard at this point is data
provenance and in fact to the my best
knowledge the the term was actually
coined by my former colleague Peter
bunam in here at Penn but other people
have called it data lineage data
pedigree and so on and in some sense
really
it's an expanded version of kind of the
scientific record and the way we
describe our experimental methodology
and and so on so as you you know think
about a process like what's visualized
on the slide where we go from data
acquisition to data analysis to
generating figures and reports and
papers all along the way we'd like to
recording as much detail as we can the
processes the assumptions the sample
size the sample settings etc that went
into the creation of each of the data
products along the way okay and you know
when you look at that at the very
earliest stage the left-most the data
acquisition side
what we tend to think about as
Providence is things like who did the
experiment under what instrument
settings and and well the context was
this is largely kind of metadata that we
need to carefully define as we move from
acquisition of the raw data from the
real world there typically are a lot of
computational steps performed you know
you run a piece of code with an
algorithm so there we tend to think
about data provenance as something that
might for instance be automatically
created maintained and logged by the
computer system itself as you're writing
as you're running your code and and so
on okay so there's a fairly different
way we think about Providence at the
first stage versus of the second stage
because the first stage is primarily
figuring out what you want to capture
the second stage is something that you
can imagine computationally supporting
an automating and I'll get into more
detail about that as we go forward with
respect to why provenance obviously one
of the big motivations for data
provenance is support for
reproducibility and validation of
results the more documentation we have
on exactly what was done the more detail
we can understand how to repeat the same
results but in fact increasingly we're
starting to put value on other uses of
provenance so one of the most important
that I've looked at in my computer
science research is if you have data
from many different providers ultimately
we can use data provenance and past
history and reliability and so on to
actually use Providence to reason about
how much you as an individual user might
want to trust or rank or look at a
particular data source
so really the reliability relevance or
value of data may also depend very much
on its provenance okay so we tend to
think of that generically as trust but
it really encompasses lots of different
things
another key place where Providence comes
into play all the time is if I am
bringing together data that was acquired
under different conditions as I'm trying
to regularize it and harmonize it in
order to conduct some kind of analysis
I may have to process data from
different sources in different ways and
that processing might involve more than
just converting the format's which we
typically do in the data wrangling stage
it might also involve regularizing it in
some particular way particularly paying
and paying attention to things like
which populations were studied in the
different the different sources and so
on
ok so data provenance helps us not just
reproduce but also evaluate and select
and assign trustworthiness to data and
finally if we look at data provenance
and we have a bird's eye perspective of
what data sources are used we're then in
fact much like we do with social
networks and the world wide web and so
on we can use for instance information
about how often a data source is used to
give some indications about how
authoritative or useful or relevant that
particular data source would be so you
can think of something at analogous to
the h-index
or to Google Pagerank or whatever being
applied to data sources if we have
visibility through data provenance okay
so lots of different reasons to use it I
want to stress that data provenance and
data are really going to be tightly
linked in our world view all the time
even though we tend to think of data and
metadata as separate things obviously
this is a kind of metadata that's
extremely useful in understanding how to
interpret a given piece of data ok so
that's the basic overview of what I want
to talk about today now what I'm going
to do is kind of drill down a little bit
to more formally explain what Providence
needs to be so
a bit of time on that and they know kind
of go through how we actually model it
computationally with tools and then some
of the applications so starting with the
formal definition let's sort of separate
into two camps as I said one of the
kinds of data provenance is Providence
over data as we're acquiring it so for
instance you know in the figure here we
have an MRI machine we might need to
annotate the individual images or the
set of images with information about
what the instrument settings were who
did the the actual experiment or data
acquisition potentially who the subject
was what experiment was being done and
so on okay and if you think of the
classic questions of who what where when
why and how basically what we're trying
to do is capture all of those the
environment the context the questions
etc okay all of this is ultimately
fairly domain specific it will depend on
what the experiments are about but it
does involve some piece of capturing
data from the instrument itself and it
may involve some additional data entry
from the people actually doing the data
acquisition so one of the big challenges
here is at some level data provenance if
you think of as an explanation of
exactly why you are doing some
particular data acquisition can be an
extremely extremely detailed record of
what you've done before and a
justification for what you're doing now
we never want to make provenance
captured too much of a burden so the
question is just how much of this
context needs to be captured and I think
here when we think about data provenance
the key challenge is trying to decide
exactly what kind of metadata on a
capture that sort of balances between
how hard it is and how much manual labor
is involved versus the level of detail
capture that might help somebody else
in the future reinterpret and reuse our
data so this first stage is really
primarily a metadata design problem as
opposed to a computational tools problem
we have to think about things like how
much of the context of the data
acquisition can we get how much is
actually going to be useful in the
future certainly one of the big
questions especially with modern sensors
and data acquisition devices is you know
if we can capture a lot of that context
automatically where a human doesn't have
to do anything that's extraordinarily
helpful and there are lots and lots of
examples of this happening in practice
you know my collaborators we do - bird
gene sequencing there's a lot of
parameter information that comes out of
that machine whenever you take a digital
photo on your smartphone there's the so
called exif data that includes all sorts
of information about the settings and
potentially even GPS and so on
increasingly people are looking at using
NFC or barcodes or various other things
to automatically capture they're set up
in the in the real world so that nobody
has to manually type in or even worse
handwrite in the metadata so in general
lots of questions here with no sort of
standardized across the world across
domain guidelines but rather some
general rules of thumb on what you
trying to capture however there are also
lots of standards available at this
point for capturing for what to capture
and what fields and how to name them and
what units with respect to this initial
data acquisition and so for instance one
of the standards bodies that our group
interacts with quite often is open em
health they have a set of predefined
fields for a lot of kinds of data
acquisition tasks that they've tried to
standardize across the community
generally here this is a standards
effort that focuses on particular
domains technology can help for instance
by automating capture
but much like database design the key
tasks here are human intensive and
involve kind of capturing the
experimental setup okay we're the more
computational and software support can
come in is when we kind of switch from
that initial data acquisition to later
processing of the data so what I have
here in the slide is a very simple sort
of sketch of some kind of gene sequence
capture an alignment job where we might
start off on the left with gene sequence
information from initial data
acquisition which was captured with some
additional metadata going through these
two red boxes that represent
computational steps for instance in a
Python script first one might filter out
low-quality sequence information the
second one might be actually trying to
align the gene sequences against some
reference genome producing some set of
alignments so as we look at this there
are multiple computational steps there
was Providence in terms of metadata
attached to the original sequence data
now the question is what do we attach to
the output of the quality filter what do
we attach the output of the aligner and
ideally can we build tools that help us
do that automatically and then
ultimately once we've captured it can we
build tools that help us to reason about
and make use of this kind of provenance
metadata so conceptually what we want to
do is take those computational steps and
essentially create a trace or a log of
here are the individual steps each step
involved certain inputs it had certain
parameters that produced a certain
output so schematically on the right you
see kind of a list of steps like read a
particularly file do some computation
like sorting rows do some computation
for instance like computing a media and
do some computation like writing to a
file that is a kind of an example of
what we might want to capture to
document our computational processes and
then of course we're going to attach it
to our output so from a tooling
perspective what we want is for instance
to be able to run a script that
automates the production of output
results from input files and we want to
potentially store that output either in
the file system or in a database and
effectively on the side what we'd like
is something equivalent to a provenance
database system whose content will also
link closely to the file as we kind of
schematically see in the right-hand of
the figure again we need to be able to
reason about provenance and data
together because we will often want to
assess the data or interpret the data
based on its linked provenance
annotations ok so conceptually it's a
simple problem of course when you try to
actually break it down into solvable
steps it ends up getting a little more
complicated okay so let's start with the
simple kind of obvious first ticket it
described why we need to slightly tweak
that and then where that ultimately has
taken the data provenance community so
the simplest form of capturing data
provenance is again during our initial
data acquisition as we read data from an
instrument will attach to the file
specific metadata tags and values for
instance about the experiment and the
configuration and date of acquisition
and the subject and whatever else is
relevant to our particular experiment
then as we support computational
processing we could build some kind of
service that essentially captures all of
the events that the computer is handling
as it for instance launches a program
opens a file writes to another file
reads from another file starts another
script and so on and so forth ok so we
can kind of monitor program execution
captured
program specific events or tasks feed it
to some logging service and then put it
into an event log which we might think
of as a kind of primitive okay and in
fact in the computer science world there
are a lot of different research efforts
that have been undertaken using exactly
this model probably the most well-known
was Margo Seltzer whose work at Harvard
on a system called Pass which basically
updated the operating system to record
all of the individual steps in reading
and writing to files okay and in fact
more recently my own group has built a
system we call providence tracker at
which I'll talk about in more detail
later which does something similar
without changing the operating system it
essentially captures all of the data
processing steps in terms of jobs being
run and inputs and outputs and then it
makes it accessible for the future okay
so there are lots of tools for doing
this the nice thing about these tools is
they capture all the individual steps
the inputs and outputs automatically we
don't have to worry about a human
entering all of that information okay
there also is a very related thing that
happens at pretty much every internet
company and any large enterprise which
is very close to Providence but people
tend to not think of it that way which
is as they process data they record logs
and logs and logs of requests for
instance from the web server of
individual queries handled of individual
steps performed all of that stuff is
really capturing the kind of data
provenance but it's being done in a
fairly ad hoc way okay and in general
for all of these log based approaches if
I just take the output of whatever the
computer actually captures it's
generally too low to be tremendously
useful for these questions of
reproducibility and these questions of
trustworthiness and reliability and
impact
and the reason is it captures all the
micro-level steps that a piece of
software read 64 bytes from one file and
wrote 32 bytes to another file and all
sorts of information about sequential
steps that may not matter it's basically
very very low level at the level the
operating system reasons about things
rather than the level that we would like
to think about as experimentalists and
so forth okay so what we'd like to do is
lift from these sort of chronological
steps in a log to something that says
this thing was produced because somebody
in particular I ran it using the
following steps and so on it's really
about causal relationships not
individual ontological steps and the
kinds of questions we want to ask are
generally about relationships between
the individual components that were
processed created etc okay so this is
going to motivate us to kind of rethink
our level of abstraction if this is too
low level can we come up with something
higher level okay second big problem is
that in general these logs get really
really irregular it's hard to process
logs from difference.i for artifacts
because they just end up looking
completely different so a second goal as
we think about provenance is we need a
standard way of capturing provenance no
matter where it came from what systems
etc okay so summary of this first part
provenance we can break it into two main
components the first is taking raw data
capturing the who what where why and how
this is primarily a data design and then
ultimately a human plus automated data
entry task this step is of course
extraordinarily important but in many
data science scenarios what we will end
up sharing and reusing may not be the
raw data it might be some kind of
derived data so our focus and especially
the focus of computer scientists like me
is on computational support for
provenance
on derived data and this is really about
capturing the individual steps the
inputs the conditions and so on for each
of the processing stages and really
describing not just fields but
relationships among the individual data
products ideally we do this completely
automatically transparently invisible to
the scientist in the worst case we will
do it semi automatically with the
scientist potentially helping out a
little bit with providing extra details
okay
other big piece is we want to make sure
that any computational support here has
standards and a way that provenance is
captured generically but it's also
extensible so that specific field
specific metadata can be added for a
given domain finally it's worth noting
our goals again our reproducibility
assessment of quality harmonization and
so forth so let's now take kind of the
goals from this first segment and look
at how we might refine the strawman
approach into something a little more
suitable for reasoning about and coming
from the database community we tend to
think a lot about data models like the
relational data model or a graph data
model similarly what we went here is a
provenance data model or a provenance
model and that's basically what we're
going to be talking about next so
broadly if we look at what we're trying
to capture in data provenance
there are really three main components
there are entities which are the things
that are being manipulated so typically
that could be something like a data file
or a data object within a file or a data
object within a data stream from a
sensor somehow or other you have these
things being fed into processing steps
and as a result other entities are being
produced okay so the first step first
component
as entities the second thing is some of
the entities for instance pieces of code
might be run as tasks and might be used
to process data so we have this generic
idea of activities some of the
activities might be processed by humans
so you know conducting some particular
manual step in processing is definitely
an activity and we might want to
abstract that and obviously a lot of the
activities are going to be running
software artifacts which really are at
some level binary files with particular
versions and timestamps and so on we're
going to be running those and processing
input entities or files using particular
parameters so activities really
represent not a piece of code or a
particular kind of noun in the system
but rather the act of doing some task
either computationally or manually and
then finally we have agents who
typically are people write the
activities are going to be invoked by
the people but sometimes also you will
have situations where a person starts
one particular computational job then
spawns a bunch of others so agents can
be both humans but they can also be
other tasks that then go on and invoke
still other tasks and so on ok so agents
basically start activities or but the
other way activities are usually
conducted on behalf of or by agents
activities typically read entities and
write entities or more more generically
they have entities that they process in
order to produce other entities so on
the bottom of this slide we have a
figure which shows again our kind of
gene sequencing
example where we see sequence data which
is an entity it's annotated by metadata
it's sorry uh and at the next step we
have a this ellipse represents the
quality check activity which has some
parameters and in fact not shown here
the quality check presumably also links
to the particular file that is the the
program being run the quality check is
being performed by our user so here we
have the little kind of house symbol
with with Bill Nye the Science Guy in it
perhaps he ran the quality check code
the output of that will be these
filtered sequences which again is an
entity then we run an aligner which
takes the filtered sequences in a
reference genome as input entities and
it produces alignments that's
essentially an abstract representation
of provenance and in fact I broadly
following the notation of one of the
standards that we're going to talk about
in a moment one thing that's kind of
interesting about the standard is that
the arrows point in the opposite
direction of data flow so if you read
this diagram initially you may get the
impression the data is going from right
to left but in fact in general these the
edges the lines and the arrows represent
sort of where things came from as
opposed to where data was fed so we're
really looking at the alignments were
created by the aligner which read as an
input the filtered sequences more
generically this standard which at this
point has had a lot of input from many
different constituencies and has become
the standard for data provenance is
called prof DM the provenance data model
is standardized by the World Wide Web
Consortium and it's actually one of a
family of prominent standards it
basically defines a syntax an abstract
representation and a basic vocabulary
for core aspects of data provenance
and so you'll sort of see in the table
on the left this notion of entities
activities and agents that I had used in
the previous example underneath that
there is a series of relationships
between these entities activities and
agents so things like something was
generated by a particular activity or
that an agent used a particular entity
or that one particular entity was
derived from another etc so this is kind
of a basic core vocabulary for
relationships between data items on the
right we see some examples of different
views of provenance graphs describing
these relationships it's worth noting
that all of the kind of white boxes in
those figures describe extra properties
this is metadata that's specific to the
domain that the data was acquired from
so these are the metadata fields that
you would customize for your particular
experiment or data modality or data
types
prov tries to give a basic core for
describing entities activities agents
and relationships and assumes that you
will augment all of that with additional
domain specific fields that hopefully
will be propagated in a straightforward
way from inputs to outputs and so on
okay so that's the basic core way of
capturing provenance in a general way
that is also extensible and in many ways
I like to make the analogy even though
it's not an exact one that one should
think of proud DM much the way one
thinks of standards like XML or JSON or
RDF which is to say there's a core
syntax that helps us share a lot of the
basic concepts but ultimately there will
be extra fields metadata and
relationships that you will need to
define and add as you go just to give
hint on how prov diem is actually
entered into the computer there are
several different formats one of them is
called prob n it's designed to be fairly
human readable so what we see in the
example here is the definition of a
bunch of entities so the first one is
the first entity is some kind of article
and we're assigning particular metadata
fields like a title to that particular
entity those things that you see before
the colons the e^x and in the DC terms
and so on are part of what's called a
namespace it's a place where individual
terms are being defined for instance
within an ontology or within a
particular schema so for the most part
you can kind of ignore that prefix and
just read this as it's we're defining an
entity which is an article and it has a
title being climb rises in cities we
have similar definitions here for data
set 1 and region lists and so on
there is also an XML equivalent format
for those who are building tools as you
can hopefully get from the example it's
much less human readable but the
advantage to XML is that there are many
many tools that automatically generate
parse and read it ok so that's what
provenance looks like ultimately there's
this kind of abstract model of graphs
between users agents and activities and
then there's this more syntactic model
which is just how we encode the basic
objects and relationships within the
graph the next question obviously should
be we have this model how in the world
are we actually going to record in
particular the provenance relationships
so there are really three main ways if
you write a particular analytics
algorithm then you know one thing that
you could do although it takes a fair
amount of work would be to have the
program itself not only produce the
output data files but in fact record
somewhere for instance a bunch of
private or
all our products and no records
describing exactly what it did okay but
that's fairly labor-intensive and
especially for code that already exists
most people will not be particularly
motivated to add this extra
instrumentation so a second thing you
can do and this has been the common
practice within a lot of the scientific
communities especially in areas like
physics and astronomy where there are
very regular processing workflows done
there are special platforms like Taverna
and Kepler and galaxy and vis trails
which basically allow you to define
sequences of computation using kind of a
boxes and arrows dataflow module
actually the loonie
effort also does something very similar
to this where different computational
steps can be cascaded together usually
using visual tools and these will be
automatically run on a server somewhere
and many of the existing workflow
engines as a byproduct will
automatically generate data provenance
to go along with the data outputs and
this is a wonderful and extremely
helpful capability however there are a
number of people and I would count among
that many of my collaborators who feel
that a large part of their data analysis
is not regular enough that they want to
use workflow system rather they want to
be able to go for instance to the Python
shell and run a bunch of particular
steps or they might want to go to the
Linux terminal and run different
programs to do some sequence of steps
and they might want to be able to change
this kind of on the fly so for these
kinds of scenarios to this point there
have not been very many answers for how
to actually capture that kind of
provenance in recent years there have
been a number of efforts to try to
actually build tools
that helped capture arbitrary executions
of programs and scripts and so on so at
NYU poly juliana Ferraris group has done
a bunch of work in this space and as i
had mentioned earlier our group here has
also done something in this space to
allow for kind of a background dropbox
like tool that just watches what you're
running and records it and generates
prog DM so i'll talk more about this a
little bit okay so that was what
provenance looks like how we actually
record it the last piece to provenance
capture is where do we actually put it
once we have it there again I want to
emphasize that one shouldn't really
think of provenance and data as living
in completely different worlds
however we typically have a solution for
where we're storing our data and it may
not be easy to gracefully extend that to
support Providence so in general the way
we think of primary storage is somewhere
we ought to have kind of a provenance
database which will really be storing
graphs and there ought to be a way of
having common identifiers between nodes
in our traditional database or data
storage system and references in the
provenance storage system so that we can
reconstruct the links between provenance
and data you know often when people hear
the provenance and prob DMR our graph
will pretty quickly gravitate toward
graph databases so things like you know
for J and orient DB and so on and that's
a perfectly good and viable place to put
provenance
but in fact one can also encode
Providence in essentially any kind of no
SQL database or relational databases
where the tables would be things like
entities and attributes and agents etc
so private does not particularly
prescribe what the underlying database
is however it does pretty well prescribe
what we want to store within the
database okay
and here there are a lot of tools that
have been built from the provi m-spec in
particular Luc Moreau who was one of the
prov one of the core leaders of the prof
movement has a very nice toolbox in open
source and a variety of groups including
ours have built expanded services over
that for trying to capture provenance
from the community so we for instance
have a have a server called Penn
Providence net where you can just upload
share and manage Prague DM data okay
what I described so far is looking at
Providence in terms of files and
computational modules so things like
programs in reality that is one piece of
the broad spectrum of how computer
scientists think about provenance there
are a lot of efforts in trying to model
Providence at a finer level of
granularity than files and programs so
for instance I might look at my file
that had lists of gene sequences and
want to specifically describe each of
those sequences as a separate input
entity and I might want to think about
my aligner program as having individual
sub steps so we tend to think of this as
going from treating files and programs
as black boxes that we don't understand
into making them kind of clear boxes or
gray boxes or white boxes we can
actually algorithmically reason about
what's going on in terms of the
individual data objects the contents and
in terms of the individual operations
and if you go to this level of detail
which has been studied heavily in the
database community and others
this lets you reason in much more detail
about how specific results as a spoke as
opposed to specific files how those were
produced and it can also in many cases
help diagnose why some results might be
different from others and so forth so
broadly I think it's important to
understand that from the Life Sciences
perspective we'll often think about file
to program to file provenance black box
provenance but there are situations
where we need this lower level of detail
or in finer level of detail and there
are technologies for that as well that's
not going to be the focus of my
presentation here but there are many
references in that and in the Q&A or in
other scenarios I'm happy to talk about
this in more detail okay so to summarize
part two we've gone from this notion of
why we want to capture provenance to the
basic core constructs of how people
encode provenance abstractly as entities
activities and agents we talked a bit
about the Prague DM standard and the
fact that it captures data flows and
relationships but allows additional
metadata to be attached we talked a bit
about different tools and mechanisms for
capturing provenance and then we kind of
highlighted the notion that actually
there are also other more detailed forms
of as kind of the last major segment
what I want to do is talk briefly about
some of the computational tasks that
people are doing or attempting to
develop techniques to do with data
provenance so one of the most common
things and one of the most commonly
supported things that we can do is to
take data items
so again files or individual records and
to build tools that will help look up
the provenance of those particular
objects and visualize it so that users
can sanity check can reproduce can
identify why and
a particular data item existed okay so
this broadly is useful for kind of
sanity checking interpretation and so on
at the manual level and it's not an
uncommon operation at all especially if
you want to reproduce results okay but
in many ways this is the simplest thing
because what it really involves is
looking up the provenance the prob DM
entry for a given entity pulling up that
piece of the graph and then running it
through interactive visualization tools
like the one that I'm showing here and a
wide variety of tools that are available
to the community well we're talking
about this I should also mention you
know question make up if you're trying
to do reproducible research and
especially for trying to authenticate it
result how do we know that what we're
visualizing is actually what was done
what if somebody came into our
provenance database and hacked to the
provenance entries well it turns out
there are a bunch of pieces of work in
the computer science space that done by
my colleagues here at Penn specifically
developing ways of using encryption and
so-called Merkel trees to help capture
the individual steps and essentially
authenticate that the provenance is
intact and has not been forged or
modified in any giving away okay so
that's provenance and it's visualization
some other things that we might want to
do are what I want to focus on for the
last couple of minutes I want to
emphasize here that most of the things
I'm going to briefly talk about are on
the active research side of the world
there are some preliminary tools for
many of them but many of them are highly
dependent on exactly what level of
detail we have in terms of the black box
operations and how they work and because
they're so dramatically affected by the
individual assumptions of the operations
the number of tools available that our
general-purpose is a bit
we're limited here so these are all
areas where I think we're going to start
to see more and more tooling and more
and more options as the next couple of
years go forward so first piece I'm
gonna mention is we might go from
visualizing Providence to reproducing
for reproduction to actually using
Providence and automating the process of
reproducing an experiment so basically
this involves for instance having a tool
where the user can identify some
particular data product and say can you
repeat the same process that was
involved in creating this data product
on my new input data item over here so
this is now really taking the provenance
and using it essentially to define a
script to run against another new piece
of data okay and then we can further
expand on that to say why don't we
reproduce and rerun exactly the script
that was used on the previous result
with one small modification so for
instance I want to replace one of the
original modules with my own module and
now I want to compare the results so
this task of automating the reproduction
and ultimately comparison and
benchmarking of different results it's
something that's computationally fairly
easy to do that can be incredibly
effective as part of the exploration and
reproduction repertoire for scientists
another big piece and one of my personal
interests is this interplay between data
provenance and both trustworthiness of
the data and impact so I had alluded a
bit to this earlier if we look at all of
our data in some progress alternately
what will happen is certain entities
will be reused in many many many
experiments and perhaps the results of
those experiments can be reused in many
many other analyses and so on
and if we have a bird's eye perspective
of what's being reused this
a wonderful opportunity to assign scores
to impact and centrality and visibility
of particular data items and the same
way that we tend to use things like the
h-index
for measuring scholarly impact or
PageRank for measuring authoritative
massive websites we can create a sharing
index or an impact index on data based
on who is using it and the building
block to that is data provenance and
having big piece that's closely related
but now focuses on single items as
opposed to the entire network of
relationships is over time as we look at
data and assess whether it is correct or
incorrect we can use machine learning
and other techniques to figure out
between all the data items that are
correct and all the data items that are
incorrect or between all the data items
that are relevant and those that are
irrelevant what is it in their
provenance that differentiates between
the good and the bad or the trusted and
the untrusted and over time we can
actually learn to put weights and scores
and probabilities of relevance on data
based purely on its provenance so that's
something that I think will continue to
become more and more important over time
as more data becomes shared and reused
in more and more and more experiments
okay really the last main piece I wanted
to briefly allude to is Providence is
also a building block toward diagnosis
and debugging
I have collaborators who run essentially
scripts over their data on a daily basis
they're acquiring new data every day
they run a script they produce some
results over time they make tweaks to
the script over time they might want to
do a historical comparison of the
results from today versus the results
from six months and sometimes the
results aren't consistent
the question is how do they diagnose
what changed and why and they're
absolutely data provenance becomes
critical to really identifying the
differences between today's script and
six months ago script and in fact we can
replay pieces of that those two scripts
and compare them in order to ultimately
help the scientist to debug what change
and potentially what went wrong in their
analysis so this is something that we're
very very interested in and actively
working on here okay
one last part related to Providence
that's worth emphasizing before we
conclude is that while I talked about
going from this very low level view of
prominence to something more abstract in
fact there are many possible levels of
abstraction I might want to have her
provenance in some cases I want to see
each individual step in some places I
may want to actually simplify or sort of
collapse together many provenance steps
into one kind of unified black box so
one of the big tasks in sort of this
view of ultimately building a provenance
database or provenance support platform
is we want to be able to do queries and
views that actually extract data and a
lot of work done by my colleague Susan
Davidson has actually focused especially
on those particular problems so in terms
of making provenance useful we can
visualize it we can use it to measure
trust and impact we can use it to
measure differences between different
results and we can use it to hide and
abstract pieces of provenance and give
us a better perspective on what really
happened so let me wrap up now but
saying I've tried to capture through the
last 50 minutes
why provenance is actually a hard
problem and it's more than just defining
it there's a data acquisition parameters
we described a bit about how we model
Providence abstractly some of the tools
and techniques available for capture
some of the tools and techniques
available or under active study for what
we can do with provenance I've mentioned
along the way that as part of our and
int educate project we've been trying to
build reusable tools for the community
and this
so I'll leave a pointer up for that and
I want to conclude by saying provenance
is still a space that is in its early
stages there's tremendous opportunity
for using this kind of metadata for
reasoning about data and I'm very
excited about where it's all headed and
I expect in five years a repeat version
of this webinar will end up looking
dramatically different as we start to
have impact so thank you for your time
and I'm happy to flip to Q&A mode as as
people of questions wonderful thank you
so much Zach that was outstanding
so everyone if you do have some
questions for dr. Ives please enter them
into the little question functionality
there that's part of the the GoToWebinar
interface
probably on the right side of your
screen and we'll try and get to those
now we've already had a few of these and
Zach the one person asked how much
activity is going on with the level of
manufacturers to make sure that critical
provenance information such as the
firmware or the you know make model and
a serial number of the scanner or the
gene sequence or whatever is getting
embedded into into raw data files so
that that it's almost like it was there
like a minimum information standard
that's available in our manufacturers
subscribing to it so that's a wonderful
question and I would say it's highly
highly variable by communities so you
know it seems like there are certain
domains where most of that information
is does seem to be getting captured I
think there also plenty of cases where
it's clear that that's not all being
captured you know it feels like this is
one of the things that at the end of the
day the research community needs to
articulate strongly to the manufacturers
that you know part of what's gonna help
us select your instrument it will be
that it records all this kind of
information I suspect there are a lot of
cases where people have firmware that
you will never see that that particular
firmware that changed or what not many
of the other parameters I think are
being captured and and are available at
least in the manufacturers file formats
I think the other thing that's always a
bit tricky is depending on the field
sometimes there is a level of detail
that is output by the instruments in
their proprietary file formats but then
once you export that data into some more
open format a lot of that detail tends
to get dropped so I think there's also
an opportunity to think about for
specific data modalities are there
things that we want to you know
encourage everybody to propagate from
the individual devices right and you
also mention that you don't want
provenance to be a burden for
researchers all right and with it with
the exception of the manufacturers
helping us to do it do you see any other
way to achieve it being kind of a simple
thing for people to do and are there any
editors or things that people can use to
help store their provenance so that's a
great question it has many many
different answers so you know I will
mention I remember that the Case Western
data provenance project that's going on
in bd2k right now such Lisa who's group
one of the things that they're actually
working on is trying to have forums and
and capture of provenance as doctoral C
patients that ends up being something
that has to be manually entered there's
been a lot of work in for instance you
know digital lab notebooks that use
tablets and one of the opportunities
there although it's still kind of
fledgling is if you have an iPad and
there are for instance barcodes or RF
IDs or Bluetooth transponders or various
other devices on for instance things in
the physical world you can imagine
extending your digital lab notebook to
record all of those individual things so
as we move to this future Internet of
Things world where
all of your instruments can talk I
suspect we're going to see more and more
automatic data acquisition for these
kinds of sensors and what was used and
so on again things like tablets will
probably help also as we switch from
physical lab notebooks but unfortunately
there's also no kind of magic wand
technology here that's going to
completely human as kind of the you know
the conduit for a huge part of that
about knowledge
so what been said you know I think as as
particular tasks mature there probably
will be more and more automation of
specific steps there all right what role
do you see librarians and archivists
basically part of the digital archive
and community what role can they play in
helping scientists and data scientists
to to do this in an effective way I
think that's one of the great
opportunities for kind of Library and
Information science community is really
helping to define and and assist with
kind of best practices and metadata
potentially actually aiding with the
maintenance of archives and and so on I
will say you know from my own
interactions with for instance our
university librarians versus the
libraries in other universities it's
still very much an open question of just
how central libraries are going to be in
this picture I personally think this
seems like a great role for them and
there are a lot of really talented
people in those fields who are working
broadly in this space and in broadly in
digital curation and digital citation
and and so on so my hope is that that
will be among their central roles
looking forward but it also feels like
that is happening for some but not all
institutions at this point in time great
one final question for you
is there any way and perhaps you discuss
some of this but maybe you want to
elaborate is there any way to
fingerprint data and its metadata and
its provenance in such a way that it's
there's a unique identifier perhaps it's
some sort of L like a hash sort of a
number that can be a unique identifier
that can also help you to make sure that
data hasn't been tampered with or
altered in any way yeah
so in fact absolutely that is the case
there are you know many cryptographic
hash algorithms that people commonly use
over the data to generate unique IDs
sometimes that ID itself is what is
shared sometimes that data but that ID
becomes a kind of signature or
certificate on the data one of the
challenges tends to be that you know at
times those intros themselves are fairly
large at times there's a question of how
you would create the signature to look
up a data item if you don't know all of
its fields so you know I think this is
an extremely important building block
toward that I think also you know coming
back to the point of security I think
one of the other pieces that that we
have to take into account is often I'll
acquire some data I'll do an experiment
I will produce an output I might hatch
or sign that output then I'd give it to
somebody else who in turn kind of does
the same thing and so on and so really
you're building kind of a you know if
you will a Russian doll of nested one
thing inside of another inside of
another and so cryptography helps us
tremendously with that but one of the
major challenges there becomes how do
you look up the cryptographic key a
particular data item that you know
exists if you don't have the key in the
first place
so it's really important and useful in a
critical building block but one has to
realize that also there are some
particular use cases that
doesn't support okay wonderful well dr.
Ives thank you so much for for giving us
a great talk on provenance and and all
that that entails I want to thank
everybody who joined us this morning and
if you do have further questions I'm
sure dr. Ives
you can go to his website there and find
out how to get in touch with him and ask
him your questions tune in again next
week everyone for our data science
seminar series we look forward to having
you thank you so much everyone enjoy
your weekend thank you